donc souvent donc michel piccoli qui est
l'un des acteurs de la rumba la rumba
vous connaissez peut-être si vous avez
quoi un peu plus de 40 ans sinon c'est
vrai que c'est pas quelque chose de très
connu disons que c'était une danse que
l'on dansait dans les années 30 kw
je pense que dans les cours de danse oui
dans les cours de l'or ont dû apprendre
à colomba je sais pas si on aurait le
dense en dehors des cours de danse ont
la dent ça c'est un autre problème moi
je vais jamais lancé surchauffe à
hydrogène
sauf avec rosen alors si votre
partenaire dont ce film c'est l'auteur
du film qu'il a écrit avec jean curtelin
ça se passe donc en 1938 roger hanin
joue le rôle d'un maintenanciers d'une
boîte de nuit il y a là des danseurs
mandat c'est un peu l'idée qu'il a vu au
départ d'ailleurs de faire travailler
les danseurs mondains et puis il ya un
policier qui est chargé de réprimer un
certain nombre de trafics qui nettoyait
la pègre parisienne et puis y'a un haut
fonctionnaire
alors ça c'est vous cette fonction vous
êtes un échange comme un vous êtes à ses
copains et que ce policier
ben oui une fois je suis enfin le
support aux fonctionnaires je suis le
chef de l'acq a good la cagoule et evora
moeurs délation
avant la guerre juste avant la dernière
guerre d'extrême droite à l'époque qui
avait une grande influence sur la montée
de ce qui nous arrive est la montée du
fascisme et il y avait collusion
quelquefois en effet entre la police les
boîtes de nuit et ses organisations
militantes vous est proposé dans le film
à roger hanin c'est un adversaire c'est
quelqu'un qui est qui qui est un homme
qui transporte la vermine
est ce que pour vous c'est oui enfin
c'est un homme qui en même temps
essaye de lutter contre contre cette
cagoule est pour et pour l'action
patriotique et qui a un chemin très
difficile à maintenir
alors vous allez voir maintenant un
extrait de ce film regardez bien la tête
que c'est fait michel piccoli si les
cheveux plus courts une moustache
regardez bien c'est donc un extrait de
la rumba
à
ça va
le palais à notre nation
j'ai quand même tué deux hommes il ya
huit ans
rigolo malade malade aux cartes
d'électeur similaires voilà bien mais à
toi aussi
mettre de l'ordre les flics ne suffiront
pas à sabrer police ce sera nous il
possédera seulement choisir entre ces
deux musiques celle là où celle là
le club dans les casernes ils se lancent
à la fiche garde à vous qu'est ce qu'un
problème
et toi ma pomme ont fait pas de
politique ici
d'accord voilà mais je vous le rappelle
ça se passe donc en 1938 et vous avez
aperçu dans cet extrait michael denard
qui fait l'un des maîtres de ballet pour
les danseurs monde bien je me demande si
c'est pas une époque bénie pour les
scénaristes et aussi pour les acteurs ça
peut être assez amusant de tourner en
costume comme cela est de retrouver une
époque non puisqu'il hextall elana ce
film c'est que c'est un conte spectacle
mais ce sont trois plans c'est en même
temps bomber des décors et des costumes
c'est une comédie musicale et cétaphil
historique je dirais que c'est une
comédie musicale politique très bien là
c'est extrêmement amusant c'est
instructif et et c'est distrayant serra
il faut pas le seul danger dans ce genre
de film c'est qu'il faut pas que ça soit
un film des décorateurs parce qu'il est
très belles choses et c'est un peu le
danger alors il faut un copain nouri al-
intrigue mais la sig est nourrie il ya
un travail de décorateur qui est quand
même très important entre autres la
boîte de nuit grâce auquel grâce à
laquelle nous avons à nos côtés aussi
marlene dietrich et 10 lama et tous et
mais parce qu'ils ouvrent tous ses
mythes extraordinaire de cette époque
qui sont toujours nos vies d'aujourd'hui
bien sûr alors dites moi une petite
question plus personnelle vous êtes
encore un homme très sévère on vous
avait dans cette scène dans la voiture
là c'est les coups de gueule
à quand un rôle de très gentil rigolo un
très gentil rigolo ça dans vos cartons
je les passe à pour l'instant et ce à
quoi ça tient à votre personnalité où se
tient à vous vous ne voulez pas jouer
des gentils à je suis tout prêt à jouer
les gentils si ça m'était arrivé déjà
c'est vrai mais je trouve qu'il ya si
longtemps que vous n'avez pas vu dans un
rôle de ces personnages anttila vous
êtes un homme
encore une fois c'est sévère oui c'est
sévère et grotesque codic sur les
meilleurs très bien alors ce qui
explique votre présence dans ce film ça
s'appelle donc la rumba c'est de roger
hanin avec roger hanin et cette belle
distribution parmi lesquels vous
retrouverez donc michel piccoli et nice
à restos qui fait le policier et guy
marchand qui chante qui champclairot
chante kirsch antilles qui retrouve ses
amours avec une assez belle se dit pas
l'imitation mes inspirations de maurice
venu le sait mieux qu'une limitation
aucune aspiration c'est ça merci de
votre visite maintenant nous ont offert
un peu de voile avec patricia